in addition Thomas Cook have made a
financial gesture of goodwill towards
both families and we hope that this will
go some way to repairing the pain that
they have suffered yeah Thomas Cook have
agreed to make substantial donations to
each of the following charities in
memory of Christian Bobby see your gas
safety British Heart Foundation cancer
research Oh NSPCC multiple sclerosis
society and inquest the Sea Org a safety
we feel we have been given a public
voice to raise awareness see your gas
safety does fantastic work to help
support families who have been touched
by carbon monoxide tragedies inquest
whose valuable assistance for bereaved
families is second to none the British
Heart Foundation cancer research a
multiple sclerosis society in memory of
Christie and Bobby's grandparents and
finally the NSPCC charity which had a
special place in Christian Bobby tart
nothing can give us back our children or
the carefree lives we want sled no one
can he raised the lifelong pain for
Christian Bobby's family and friends we
cannot change the past and we accept
that it may be time to look to the
future we have asked Thomas Cook to push
forward our request to demolish bungalow
1 12 so that it can be a lasting tribute
in the form of a playground in the spot
where Christian Bobby died we would like
to thank Fiona Burrell and Gemma vine of
Leicester moral solicitors in Leeds who
support and expertise along with the
assistance of the charitable
organization inquest have been
invaluable huge thanks to our QC Leslie
Thomas through his faith in our case and
supporting us the underdogs in our fight
against a corporate giant I hope that
Thomas Cook and everyone who has did
it's wrong doings now realizes the
impact of their actions on families like
ours and that they will learn the
lessons they need to learn from this
tragedy we look forward to some
normality to our lives in the sure and
certain knowledge that we've done
everything we can to get justice the
Christian Bobby's deaths thank you I
would like to add one thing we would
like to thank the general public whose
voices had been heard in the media in
social media Twitter it was because of
the support of the general public we
feel that our voices have been heard
thank you very much
you